there's no avoiding death in me Oh even
if you're gifted enough to stay alive
corpses litter as many moonlit war-torn
locales it's a dark vision of Japan
during the aftermath of the violence and
Goku period in the early 17th century
it's a time of upheaval seeing through
new perspectives in neo by the fluid yet
demanding action game designs of team
ninja and from the narrative view of
navigator and trader William Adams as is
koa tech most traditional historical
figures Adams is reputation and prowess
as the first Western samurai are
elevated to supernatural status while
his skills and powers befitting a game
dense with hostiles and hazards it has
less in common with ninja gaiden and
more with the recent works of from
software
even when neo plays like a superb
spinoff of Dark Souls it has so far
shown potential in carving its own
identity
for instance while it shrines functions
similarly to Dark Souls is progress
saving bonfires they are not necessarily
safe havens since a shrine becomes
inaccessible if an enemy is nearby
by and large Neos demons and possessed
humans move with more assertiveness and
emotion than anyone you'll find in Dark
Souls you'll hear it in there growls
when they spot you
and in there grunts as they labor to
swing heavier weapons with two hands and
no matter how victorious you are winds
mean little unless you make it back to
your shrine to redeem your experience
and level up neo's environments can be
deceptive and you quickly learn to stay
on your toes at all times
demons stand in plain sight at the end
of hallways hoping you'll charge ahead
carelessly without anticipating his
buddy hiding around the corner you feel
smart when you've methodically lured a
possessed ninja into a one-on-one battle
conversely you feel idiotic when an
enemy capitalizes on your cockiness or
carelessness
that's the twisted beauty of neo it
pulverizes you the moment you don't
respect the foes abilities that includes
any attempts at brute forcing your way
to victory in neo even a weapon with
high attack power like an axe is better
in the hands of a patient player than a
persistently aggressive one aggressive
habits are understandable if you prefer
blood board since health replenishes
every time you deal damage conversely
stamina which determines the amount of
actions you can perform in the brief
span of time takes immense skill to
replenish a neo like the efficient
movements of a veteran samurai stamina
management in neo requires mindful
execution where every strike has purpose
the fact that enemies are also subject
to the limits of stamina is a standout
feature creating a level of combat death
not found in From Software's games
mastering stamina replenishment has as
of yet not been a prec juez it for
advancing a neo
instead you can defeat its bosses by
mixing thoughtful tactics and proactive
using of the games of many consumables
it's also an immense help that each
weapon has an expansive moveset spread
evenly across three fighting stances
it's gratifying to have the presence of
mind to switch between these poses in a
duel and besting an enemy without
wasting a single action makes you feel
like a veritable badass the myriad
variables to consider when it comes to
weapon choice combat stance and moment
to moment strategies almost feels
overwhelming but having all these
options is turning out to be one of neo
strengths the wealth of loot collected
from a dozen vanquished foes
can turn you into a weapons user of
multiple disciplines jumping from sword
to spear to hammer in the span of an
hour and even if you do become familiar
with all five weapon types there's also
the consideration of forgoing the
defensive security of an armored samurai
in favor of the less protected get more
agile ninja persona it remains to be
seen if this degree of diversity will be
a detriment to long-term success but so
far neo has been a punishing yet
gratifying excursion for Jack's of all
trades even after spending roughly 40
hours Neos progress menus implied I
still have another 40 to go given it's
collectibles have practical value I have
additional incentives to fully explore
the game's many already engrossing
environments the increased levels that
result from these thorough searches also
help make the boss fights less of a
headache given the varying degrees of
hardships I've encountered up to this
point I can't wait to see what devious
tricks the remaining bosses have up
their sleeves as I Forge through the
rest of the game
[Music]